Bem-vindos de volta!
Espero que todos tenham instalado o GHC
e brincado um pouco digitando
expressões.
O que iremos fazer agora é ir
além de simples expressões
e ver como podemos carregar
programas Haskell completos
no GHC.
Em Haskell, programas não são chamados
programas. Normalmente pessoas do Haskell
referem-se a seus códigos
como scripts porque
programas em Haskell são, talvez,
mais curtos do que código normal.
Eu apenas os chamo de programas
Haskell,
mas a linguagem em haskell
é scripts.
Novas funções, se vocês querem
definir um programa completo em Haskell,
defina elas em um
arquivo texto que contenha uma lista de
definições de funções
e este arquivo texto
tenha um sufixo .hs que indica
que é um
arquivo Haskell.
Igual um arquivo HTML tem um
.html sufixo, ou arquivos CSS tem
sufixo .css, ou arquivo Java
tem um sufixo .java,
um arquivo Haskell é chamado
qualquer coisa
.hs. Isso não é obrigatório,
mas é útil que vocês possam ver quando
listarem os arquivos em um diretório
possam ver que
é um script Haskell.
Agora quando vocês
estiverem usando o GHC,
o que vocês fazem é editar o seu
script em uma janela, usando qualquer
editor de sua escolha,
e então sempre que vocês fizerem uma alteração,
carreguem seu
script no seu GHC e comecem
executar expressões.
Então, este é o tipo de fluxo
que usaremos na maioria do curso.
Para coisas simples
isso é o que vocês fazem. Claro, quando estiverem
construindo aplicações comerciais em Haskell
não é assim que vocês fazem.
Vocês compilarão eles em executáveis
standalone,
mas para o propósito deste curso, este
é o fluxo: temos
a janela do editor aberta, temos o
interpretador GHCi aberto
e então carregaremos os scripts.
Neste caso,
criaremos um
arquivo texto test.hs e nele
definimos duas funções.
A primeira:
double of x equals x + x
- faz o que promete -
e então podemos quadruple
chamando double of double of x.
Então salvamos aquele arquivo
e iniciamos o
GHCi invocando o ele com
test.hs e agora ambos a biblioteca
padrão Haskell quanto
e as funções quadruple e
double que definimos
no test.hs estarão disponíveis.
Por exemplo, podemos chamar
quadruple of 10
and it will return 40, but we can also
still call all the standard library
functions. For example
we can take
double of 2 of this list. Double of 2 is
4, so this is the same as take 4,
so we take the first 4 elements
of the list.
Now what we do
is we just leave GHC open, we
returnw to our editor and
add
2 new definitions: one is factorial
and the other one is average.
Since we're starting here,
we are using some syntax that
we haven't introduced yet so
bear with me.
So product
of 1 to n - this thing here
is the list of values 1 up to n -
and then product is the
standard library function
that multiplies all the values
in a list, so
this is a good definition of factorial.
Then when we want to calculate the
average
of a list we sum
all the elements - the values of the elements -
and we divide that
by the length of the list.
Of course, this is not a very smart
implementation of average, but that
doesn't matter... we're not
here to define average, we're doing
this to learn
GHCi. The thing that we're using here is
this trick here in Haskell
is that when you put a function name
between these single back quotes,
it becomes an infix operator.
So if you write
x `f` y
that's really just syntactic sugar for
f x y. Some people like this thing
as an infix operator,
others like it just as a regular
operator
- it's your choice.
This is syntactic convention. So this is not
a string or anything,
it's really taking a function and turning
that into an infix operator.
Then in GHCi, we call reload
and it will read the file
test.hs, add all the new bindings that we just
defined
- that was for factorial, so we can now
call factorial
and then we can call average as well.
Here you see the workflow:
you have your GHCi open, your editor
you edit, you call reload, and then you
can try
your code out.
A few syntactic
things, or oddities in Haskell:
functions
and parameter names must begin with
lower case
letters.
If you define a function, it must be
of any of these forms.
But any of these
starts with a lower case
letter. You can use a regular quotes
if you're too lazy to
invent a name. That's
something that I often miss in other
languages, where I just want to say
x prime or
x double prime, et cetera.
If you define a type, a type
has to start with an
uppercase name and that's the
reason. In Haskell,
the types and identifiers
are in different namespaces and that's
determined
by whether it starts with a lower case or
upper case identifier. That can be
confusing if you come from a different
language like
Java, or C# or JavaScript.
The other thing is that in
Haskell we use
a very mild form of Hungarian
notation.
If a parameter has an
s suffix, so for example if you have a
parameter named
xs or ns or nss,
that means a list of values
of type x and this is a list of
values
of type n - sometimes the n doesn't
correspond to the
type name - but typically when you see an
s at the end you know that it's a list.
If there's 2 s's at the end
- like here -
you know that it's a list of lists.
Thats by convention. So if you want to
look like a real Haskell programmer,
you should always use this convention.
When your parameter is a list,
it always ends with s, and usually
Haskell identifiers are short
so you don't it elements,
you call it xs.
Another
interesting thing that Haskell has in
common with by Python
is that white space is significant.
The
exact rules are quite subtle, but
we are just using Haskell
in very simple ways, so this
is kind of sufficient. If you have a
sequence of definitions - like here -
they all have to start in the same
column. Here
a, b and c all start
in the same column.
In this case here,
b has a space to the left of it,
so now all these definitions don't start
in the same column.
That's wrong!
Or in this case, c
and a don't start in the same column as b..
also wrong.
White space is significant in Haskell,
so make sure that all your definitions
are lined up - this is called the layout rule.
The layout rule
is there to avoid writing
unnecessary syntax.
Haskell folks
like to write this:
a = b + c where
and then in the where clause we have
a list of definitions that
all start in the same column and then d
here stars in the same column as a,
so that belongs to the same group
as a.
You can write this with explicit
curly braces and semicolons
- if you want to -
but that looks a lot more
verbose.
Haskell programmers like brevity,
so they'll often use significant white
space.
This looks a little bit clowny.
In the Haskell world, when you write code like
this people will look like
"you didn't do enough wax on, wax off".
Here's some GHC commands that are
useful
and I really
invite you to play around with it
When you do the exercises for
subsequent lectures, make sure that you
leverage
GHC or whatever other compiler you use,
to help you. We have seen
reload, but you can also just
load a fresh script.
From the interpreter
you can open the editor, so you can edit
a file with a certain name,
or edit the current script.
This one here is super useful:
it gives the type of an expression and I do
this
all the time - I never write types myself.
I ask what the type is and I go
in the editor and paste in the type.
You definitely should use :?
and that gives you a list of all the
commands
with a small explanation.
Of course,
I hope that you will not use this
last command to quit GHC,
but that you will, for the next
eight weeks,
be constantly using GHC.
There will be a lot of exercises
and the exercises will be on the website.
All these exercises,
you should be able to
do them in any language. You don't
have to use
GHC, but in this case, since this lecture
is about
GHC, they will be
GHC-specific.
In general,
as I said in the very first lecture, this
is a course
about functional programming. It's not a
course about Haskell and it's definitely
not a course about GHC,
but in this specific case the exercises for
this chapter and
for this lecture are on GHCi.
Happy hacking and
see you all next week!